gg 118 ans dans quelques jours sur
religieuse parce que le banc devant
voulu human bomb il est
une façon parfaite
[Musique]
c'était la guerre aura eu très peur de
la loi de mauvaises nouvelles j'avais un
frère qui malheureusement a été blessé
et un qui est revenu sa naissance et qui
s'était engagé à 18 ans il a été
officier gens et j'ai plus fiers de leur
pays être français c'est mérité la
valeur de 2 aujourd'hui à 10h revenu
j'avais
16 ans alors j'ai été heureux comme tout
[Musique]
on
aime pas mais assure que religieuse
parce que le bon dieu a voulu lima human
bomb idée
d'une façon parfaite je ne trouvais pas
à aimer infos que j'ai fréquenté
les choses religieuses
l.toure barde un champ à un moment donné
je dis ma voix ma voix je vais être
religieuse et chari moi j'aimais le bon
dieu par dessus tout il m'a bien rendu
[Musique]
pour les enfants j'en ai fait beaucoup
beaucoup mais peut-il me manque et où
vous savez pas que que j'ai retrouvé
le plus jeune qui a qui à 82 jeunes en
précis que
personnellement moi
alors j'aime bien les gens qui
s'occupent des personnes âgées
sinon c zéro en jeu rend pas compte de
ce qu elles ont fourni
que le beau joueur que j'aurais à leurs
familles à jour des trésors ça oui
[Musique]
quelqu'un vient vous aimez est la
seconde elle est partie et bt et fodé
d'amérique après je n'ai plus de
nouvelles alors mandaté faudrait elle
est morte elle avait six mois de plus
que moi oh non je ne peux pas gagner
je n'ai pas du tout envie
[Musique]
où
mon désir c'est de mourir et demain et
de trop grande roue et mon frère non non
j'ai pas eu peur d'abord un jeu je crois
que je peux faire confiance aux brousses
je ne sais pas si mauvais confiance mais
je sais qui il tarde à l'énergie
impression j'ai oublié je le lui dis
toujours
[Musique]
ni
même
vous savez la droite ou la gauche ça me
charge par je n'appréciais que les gens
je ne me mets pas du président de la
république à ce moment là je m'occupe
use d'un petit chargeur vos louis je
suis allé voir sa maison
et sa femme et à sa fin et manquait
toujours après j'aime bien giscard
[Musique]
c'est pour quel journal c'est pour le
figaro ma soeur à au figaro c'est beau
jour ils sont bons c'est bon le figaro
[Musique]